you know you said talk about disneyland
and i think it was in um
i don't know what year was oh wait or
sonata wait literally prior to that
when blockbuster got approval to build
an amusement park in miami a massive
little park that they were going to
build i mean the stories
that they have uh uh is uh is insane of
what they were doing at one point
but are you guys profitable right now is
enough business coming in where you're
staying
okay that's great what you know going
back i run a business
i have 16 17 000 insurance agents
nationwide
uh i'm the ceo and the founder of the
company i do this on the side it's not
what i do full-time
what were some innovative campaigns
where
for you if you were to say you know like
mcdonald's came out with an innovate
campaign called
share a coke and they would put a name
on there bob mary jack oh my gosh let me
i'm not even a coke person jack let me
take you to my friend bob let me take
you to work it'd be cool
to share with them it's a great campaign
that they did right you see a lot of
different companies
that do great campaigns what are some
things you think they could have done at
that time with the late fee
that would have been a great campaign or
even any other campaigns they could have
done
that maybe would have brought back the
customers have you i'm sure
there's been a lot of discussions a lot
of topics talks about that
what are some things they could have
done well i think they could have done
more charitable things
and and i don't know now i say that
um but i don't know all the things that
they were doing behind the scenes kit
but all you ever really saw was oh yeah
they're doing the oh they had like an
awards like a blockbuster awards thing
kind of like the oscars kind of a thing
i mean not to that level but i know they
had an awards thing
um i think you're right about the
amusement park i mean you always saw
these big huge things we were doing um
for them and maybe they should have done
more for others
and i think that you know for us for
example like the airbnb thing you know
we
we really supported our local humane
society which is a huge thing for us
and in central oregon we're all about
pets and animals and and all of those
things and
um you know we try to support as many
things but with late fees
i would love to have seen them you know
if you're going to keep them the late
fees that you are maybe
say for every you know dollar we get for
late fees we're giving a dollar to a
local charity
i mean i think that a lot of times you
got to focus on your communities that
you're
in and i mean even um
you know i've worked for lots of
different businesses too and and done
different things over the years
and i find that if you focus more on the
on the local aspect and the person
that's in your business
at that time and you're focused on that
person and not so much
about what's happening outside it's
going to bring back tenfold
and i mean i i talk about the first week
we became the last one in america
i remember i had a customer you know we
were super busy we were not expecting
that we we had no
uh you know i was in the parking lot
across the street my son had been in a
fender bender and i was talking to a
police officer when usa today called me
and i had no idea that this was coming
and i remember being in our store and we
were super busy
and we were helping customers and i
can't remember if it was the new york
times or the washington post but one of
them called
and they were on the phone and they're
like oh my god it's the new york times
and i was like
okay well i got a customer in front of
me and the customer's like but it's the
new york times i'm like
but you're a pain customer and you're
the reason i'm here i'm like the new
york times can wait
let me let me check you out and then and
everybody was shocked that i did that
i'm like no it's like you know i think
it's exciting and it's fun and i'm so
happy to be on all these programs
but the bottom line is that customer in
front of me is what's paying
my wage that's what's keeping my doors
open and if i lose that
and if i lose that attention to my local
customers
then we're not going to be here for
another you know
20 years i mean we have to stay focused
on that and so i think sometimes in the
corporate world
that gets forgotten and i think if they
had maybe paid more attention to those
things
you know allowed their employees like we
we do fun stuff you know we have an
employee pick
section and we do we have a barbecue
that we do every year and we were doing
it in my
um my backyard but last year we actually
did it at the store because there were
so many ex-employees that were coming
and it was so fun and you know we do
more of those kind of things that are
more focused on it
and you know i'm known as the
blockbuster mom
and unfortunately now i'm starting to be
known as the blockbuster grandma which
i'm like oh my gosh i'm not you're
sure i've got my own grandkids i'm not
sure if i'm ready for that yet but i i
really think that that's important to be
a part of that and i i know i'm probably
from an hr manager standpoint probably
their biggest nightmare
because you know i love my employees i
love my customers this is my family yeah
how i operate the business every day and
i think if more
businesses treated things like a small
business
they would be more successful if they
kept track of what's happening
right now in my store today what's
happening and not worry about what might
happen tomorrow
and focus on the here and now i mean
and that's they train us like that for
our our personal lives right
it's all about being mindful it's all
about you know you gotta be mindful of
your situation be mindful of what's
happening now and not do the what
ifs and i mean you have to do some of
those as a business owner you have to
you know you have to know your cash flow
is good you have to know that you have
to plan for those things but
when it comes to customers you have to
focus on here and now every customer
that leaves my business
unhappy that doesn't fi if i can't find
a movie for them watch even if i don't
have that new release on the shelf
i need to be out there helping them find
something else so that they leave happy